hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast keynote presentation -
mari oxygenation basic and therapeutic
considerations presented by dr. jorge
per day the professor and endowed chair
in hyperbaric medical research in
emergency medicine at UC san diego
health system i'm susie valdez elaborate
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes laberd's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual event
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
our presentation just click on that
green Q&A button located at the lower
left of the presentation window and type
your questions into the box that appear
on the screen dr. per today we'll be
following up with your questions via my
email also please notice that you'll be
viewing the presentation in a slide
window to enlarge that window just click
on the screen icon located at the lower
right if you have any trouble hearing or
seeing the presentation click on the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button and let us know you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left hand corner
and follow the process to obtain your
credit without further ado please join
me in welcoming our keynote speaker dr.
George for today I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome dr.
Perez a
welcome I'm dr. George Peugeot say from
the emergency medicine department at
UCSD where I chair the translational
research program in hyperbaric medicine
today today I'd like to review with you
the opportunity to use tumour
reoxygenate in therapy and to review
some of the basic research related to
this so to orient us to the tumor
micro-environment
I use this this picture diagram of the
cellular components that can be found
within a tumor micro-environment and you
can appreciate the variety of cells as
well as the complex interactions between
cells we have resident tumor cells
somatic resident or host cells along
with inflammatory cells of different
sorts and there's complex interactions
that are occurring between all of these
different cells and as the tumor
progresses the oxygen tension within
this area decreases and throws another
level of complexity into the tumor and
host interactions and this is depicted
here in this diagram where the perfusion
of a tumor is in a occurs in a graded
response the micro vessels penetrate
from from capillaries inward and as as
we go through a zone of low oxygen
tension and then ultimately to necrosis
and the important point of this picture
is that there as the tumor grows there's
a severe selection pressure that happens
on the malignant cells that really
drives out a malignant phenotype and
this malignant phenotype is
characterized by resistance to all forms
of therapy this is an example of a renal
cell cancer that sits
in us in a hypoxic state so they this is
how we visualize oxygen tensions within
experimental tumorous this is one method
where a dye is injected in the green
represents the capillary the black is
well perfused tissue and then the red is
is the hypoxic tissue and again this is
the zone where we know there's
resistance to cell therapy and this is
really the target in which we are
looking at 2 to reoxygenate we're
familiar with the the Cascade oxygen
delivery from the air we breathe it 150
millimeters or 21% through the lungs and
vascular system down to the level of the
micro circulation and tissue where were
at about 3.5 percent or 25 millimeters
of mercury for purposes of this
presentation hyperoxia will be defined
as greater than 150 millimeters of
mercury
normally at 20 to 150 and then hypoxia
is 20 but understand that hypoxia as a
dynamic definition indicates that there
is demand is exceeded the supply of
oxygen and leads to disease the tumor
microenvironment is I pointed out due to
poor perfusion we we see barriers that
result in decreased drug delivery to
tissue
however the hypoxia further reduces the
responses to radiation drug and
immunotherapies and the hypoxia sets up
a chronic inflammatory State which
further reduces immune responses within
that micro environment and finally
there's a severe metabolic derangement
characterized by both anaerobic and
aerobic glycolysis that is the subject
of this well-written text book by dr. Z
free from Boston College and I will not
get in into the metabolic aspects any
further this is an example of
hypoxia within human tumors this is work
from dr. opal from Peter vocal from
Germany who has spent a lifetime
charting and characterizing tumor
hypoxia and humans this is a histogram
with the frequency versus the oxygen
tensions and as you can see and this is
Brett normal breast tissue there's
there's oxygen tensions that would fall
in mostly into the norm oxic range as we
find in breast cancer and in cervical
cancer this histogram becomes skewed to
the severely hypoxic and this can
further be demonstrated in growing
tumors that as they grow increasing
volume leads to hypoxia so this is
approximately this is an experimental
tumor model where the histogram shows
nor Marcia however once we reach
approximately one centimeter tumor
volume oxygenation begins to fall off
and hypoxia dominates so what we what we
know is hypoxia is linked to poor
clinical outcomes this is related to
tumor aggressivity therapeutic
resistance and poor clinical outcomes
and again I would refer the audience to
work done by dr. Vogel and his his group
more recently it's been recognized again
the hypoxia
within the tumor micro-environment is
driving the malignant phenotype and this
has been popularized now by doctors
Menza who is the founder and discoverer
of v one alpha
gene this is another example of if of
the effect of hypoxia on radio
sensitivity and this is disease-free
survival in years head and neck
radiation therapy and what's found is if
the tumor has an oxygen tension of less
than 10 millimeters of mercury
then the disease-free survival drops off
significantly so we know that hypoxia
also induces inflammation this is a
major second downstream affective
hypoxia and that inflammation itself
contributes to the malignant phenotype
and so we all are familiar with the
severe amount of edema and swelling and
inflammation associated with solid
cancers this is one example of a brain
tumor demonstrating severe tissue edema
this has been reviewed in this nice
monograph and has been now studied in
terms of identifying mechanistic links
between hypoxia and inflammation and one
example here human monocytes when
exposed to chronic hypoxia become
pro-inflammatory we also know that
during hypoxia tissue is damaged
mitochondrion become damaged and release
their contents this actually mimics very
much what happens during a bacterial
infection where so-called pants are
released in our pro-inflammatory and
induce a inflammasome type reaction well
the same thing is happening in a sterile
environment under low oxygen tension we
see a damage to the mitochondrion and a
release of mitochondrial DNA which has a
very similar effect to stimulate
inflammation this has further been shown
that hypoxia will by causing injury will
will release these damage associated
molecular patterns and stimulate the TLR
receptor which then triggers an NF Kappa
beta and again we have a huge release of
cytokines and inflammation and so I've
just shown you the hypoxia induces
inflammation but we also know that
inflammation in turn will stimulate and
induce a
or profound state of hypoxia and thus we
have a positive feedback loop occurring
this hypoxia inflammation inducing
hypoxia was described in the 80s in the
context of infectious diseases and this
is a wire mesh cage that was implanted
subcutaneously and one that is not
infected and then a cage that is had
bacteria introduced to mimic infection
and what you can see is a significant
reduction from 63 millimeters of mercury
partial pressure down to 4.5 or hypoxic
region so we know inflammation induces
hypoxia another example of that is the
human tuberculin reaction this has been
well worked out by a group in Scotland
where they looked at transcutaneous
oximetry overlying a human to positive
human tuberculin reaction and counted
the cell density and as cells migrate
the increasing cellular number is
associate with reduced oxygen tension
again an example that inflammation is
inducing hypoxia one mechanism that is
well worked out and has been known for
many years is the so-called respiratory
burst where a white blood cell
neutrophil will consume oxygen at
prodigious levels to to produce reactive
oxygen species that are then critical
for killing of bacteria so this is a
highly conserved in a very potent
response in addition inflammation
further causes tissue edema this leads
to diffusion barrier or blockade and
perpetuates or exacerbates the hypoxia
and also the inflammation leads to micro
vascular injury and likewise further
reduces the oxygen tension within the
tissue so this positive feedback loop is
referred to as inflammatory hypoxia
and it is a self-fulfilling positive
cycle which independent of whether
inflammation starts causing the hypoxia
or hypoxia starts causing the
inflammation the two of them then build
on one another in a irreversible cycle
is established this has gotten a recent
press and interest by dr. Alt sig from
University of Colorado who is elegantly
described this relationship and what we
know is there's a profound amount of
molecular crosstalk and potential
targets that are common to both
inflammation and hypoxia I've recently
put together the concept that many
diseases not just cancer are suffering
from a problem of inflammatory hypoxia
and that tissue reoxygenate has a
potential for opening new therapeutic
avenues so overcoming the inflammatory
hypoxia barrier drug therapies have been
tried anti-inflammatory drugs
immunotherapies hypoxia sensitizers and
nanoparticle gene therapy all of which
have some modicum of effect but are not
robust so we know the predominant way
that inflammatory hypoxia is treated
today is with drugs anti-inflammatory
drugs ignoring largely the other half of
this equation or this cycle and we
wondered if adding in hyper hyperbaric
oxygen or reoxygenate in tissue and will
eventually require hyperbaric doses to
effectively do that might not influence
and be able to break this vicious cycle
tumor reoxidation be therapy began many
years ago in the 70s when it was
recognized by dr. gray that radiation
killing of radiation radiation killing
of tumors was very sensitive to oxygen
tension
and he called this the oxygen
enhancement effect this was shortly
thereafter taken into the clinic where
Churchill Davison began treating
patients with tumors in a hyperbaric
chamber at 3 atmospheres of oxygen and
was able to compare was able to radiate
half of the tumor volume while in the
hyperbaric chamber and they showed
significant killing of the hyperbaric
exposed tumors this is just one example
of early work showing survival versus
radiation dose and in 150 millimeters of
mercury a human pancreatic cancer
xenograft is very sensitive to the
effects of radiation less so at 40
millimetres and even less so in a
hypoxic environment this was then tested
in an animal model and these are
historical historical work that shows an
animal that had sarcoma injected into
both limbs this limb was irradiated
while the animal was breathing
hyperbaric oxygen in this limb while the
animal is breathing air and as you can
see the dramatic effect anti-tumor
effect that the combination oxygen and
radiation has had in this model this was
then again by dr. Churchill Davidson
tested in patients and
and this one report eight patients were
studied and all tolerated this treatment
without adverse effects and effects in
six of the eight showed significantly
increased tumour killing this then had
its heyday in the early 70s where a
number of programs began in radiating
patients through mono place chambers and
there were some technical difficulties
around this approach more recently the
effects of hypoxic modification on
radiation responses have been reviewed
in this meta-analysis and as you can see
on this fourth foster plot that both
local regional and and disease specific
survival improve if you modify the
hypoxic environment now the the
modification came by several methods
shown here one is by normal barrack
oxygen therapy showed a mild improvement
to the left of the no effect line means
that the the hypoxic sensitizer is
active hyperbaric oxygen actually showed
the largest effect in terms of local
regional control in a number of hypoxic
sensitizers had minimal effect again in
terms of disease specific death the same
pattern is seen a small effect with
normal barrack a significant effect with
hyperbaric and a limited to no effect
with the hypoxic sensitizers the other
point i would like to make with this
slide as you can see the total numbers
here the normal barrack oxygen is 377 to
ninety to ninety nine and then
over a thousand sixteen hundred patients
and in one of the barriers to hyperbaric
oxygen therapy is just that that these
are difficult studies to perform and
therefore sample sizes are typically
smaller when compared to drugs more
recently a renewed interest in
incorporating hyperbaric oxygen ation
has appeared for supporting radio chemo
surgery in multiple malignancies
including brain this is a recent report
feasibility abstract that was done from
Dartmouth and again showing that
hyperbaric oxygen could be combined with
chemo radiation protocols without
adverse with a significant change in
adverse events
another study recent study from Japan
showed an identical thing that adding in
hyperbaric oxygen to chemo radiation is
feasible and safe so the biggest one of
the biggest concerns about the use of
hyperbaric oxygen in the setting of
malignancy is does it cause or promote
cancer growth dr. Feld Meyer who is a
radiation oncologist has studied this
and reported on this extensively and
continues to find no positive effect of
hyperbaric oxygen in the setting of
cancer therapy data that I like to quote
is from early work by dr. Robert marks
who used radio used hyperbaric oxygen to
treat or a maxillofacial
injury from radiation so-called well
when a RN and what we what we're seeing
here is a five year follow-up of those
patients by stage whether they received
control no hyperbaric or hyperbaric and
what we find is there's no significant
difference in the recurrence at any
stage over five years if a patient had
received hyperbaric and and as you know
there's residual disease in many of
these patients and if hyperbaric was
going to stimulate tumor growth it
should be seen here
when investigators have gone to the
laboratory to look specifically at this
question they have failed to find and if
a positive tumor promoting effect of
hyperbarics another concern about its
use especially in the setting of
radiation therapy is that the patients
are inside the chamber and when they
leave the chamber they quickly D
oxygenate the tumor quickly D oxygenates
and so any adjunctive benefit is quickly
lost this is one example that shows
tumor deoxygenation this is this is the
skeletal muscle that oxygenates quickly
but the tumor lags and it's likely due
to dysfunctional micro circulation and
that once the tumor gets saturated
there's a time period where the oxygen
tension remains elevated so what about
tumor immunology is there a role for
reoxygenate as we know early work showed
the micro environment was
immunosuppressive and that was led to
some dismal outlooks in terms of
immunotherapy however recently with the
immune checkpoint inhibitors
there's been
new and improved outcomes however this
demonstrates again that there are
associated with any of these therapies
new barriers all related to drug
delivery toxicity and resistance this is
one diagram that shows the the
immunosuppressive environment that gets
established due to the hypoxia
adenosine is involved in this response
but we get we get T reg cells and do an
immunosuppressive macrophage phenotypes
that get driven out and really inhibit
any type of immunotherapy within that
tumor micro-environment
efforts have been made to break that
immuno depressed state by both chemo and
radiation
adding chemo and radiation therapy to
the tumor micro-environment and more
recently this paper appeared where
investigators had provided supplemental
oxygenation to enhance anti-tumor
effects of their immunotherapy and this
approach was suggested by their prior
work in which hypoxia was shown to drive
increased adenosine receptor signaling
within the tumor micro environment and
this depicts a experimental lung model
of methyl colon thering induced
fibrosarcoma and these are lung
metastases and these animals were
treated with 21% oxygen or 60% oxygen on
day 11 after implantation of the tumors
or or at day zero and what we can see is
a dramatic ink number of cancer deposits
within these lungs with a significant
reduction due to 60% oxygen and a
further reduction if the oxygen was
started early and this is depicted here
with a very significant reduction
survival was also improved by the
animals that had received the
supplemental oxygen therapy and they
also applied it to a spontaneous
metastatic cancer and found the same
same oxygen in effect a Rick review of
drug synergy that's out there again
multiple cases I won't I only put these
here for reference but there's multiple
examples of where hyperbaric oxygen will
synergize with conventional immuno or
chemo therapy to kill cancer cells and
more recently a interesting paper has
shown that by modifying the diet and
providing ketone based diet that the
addition of hyperbaric oxygen again
shows significant improvement in
survival and survival time in in the
setting of this dietary manipulation so
why hyperbaric off why hyperbaric oxygen
to reoxygenate we know that it's purely
about a concentration gradient and while
normal beric oxygen will achieve summary
oxygenation it won't be complete and in
order to get effective for maximal cell
killing within solid tumors we believe
hyperbaric oxygen doses are going to be
required so I want to address some of
the knowledge gap around hyperbaric
oxygen for those of you who may not be
familiar with it it is a drug it's
considered a drug it is widely available
and safe it will overcome this diffusion
barrier it also has a direct
anti-inflammatory effect that is not
seen with normal Berrick oxygen as I
showed you it has potential to synergize
with all forms of anti-cancer treatment
it also leads to a reduction in tissue
edema and can reduce reactive oxygen
species liberation in compromised tissue
the FDA considers hyperbaric oxygen
therapy actually a combination therapy
the drug is oxygen the devices the
chamber there's there's labeling
specifically related to normal beric
oxygen therapy the hyperbaric oxygen
therapy
is depicted here we dosed this according
to partial pressure and the green
represents the oxygen this is 21% oxygen
at one atmosphere of pressure and as we
increase the partial pressure just by
normal barrack oxygenation all of the
gases now oxygen and then we further
increase the density of that gas by
increasing the barometric pressure to
two or three atmospheres and this drives
the partial pressure of oxygen to very
high levels
this is a typical therapeutic algorithm
that is used to treat patients for
carbon monoxide poisoning with
increasing pressures up to three
atmosphere the green represent oxygen
the yellow bars are the air brakes that
are used to minimize CNS oxygen toxicity
again normal Berek hyperoxia is 21
they're 20 to 200 percent and then the
hyperbaric therapeutic range is 1.5 to 3
atmospheres this is delivered by way of
rigid pressurised devices a mono placed
chamber a multi place chamber there's a
lot of confusion in the in the lay press
around these other devices this is a
home hyperbaric air unit there's no
oxygen except what's in ambient air and
it's 1.1 is pressurized to 1.1
atmospheres
topical oxygen is pressurized again this
is a hundred percent oxygen pressurized
to one point one these are not
hyperbaric treatments and they have not
been approved by FDA I want to take a
minute just to talk about the
therapeutic wedge that hyperbaric oxygen
offers there is unit it is unique and
that's this oxygen hemoglobin binding
curve that we all learn in medical
school and we're told that we basically
the oxygen bound to
a significant part of the
oxygen-carrying equation and that oxygen
delao dissolved in the serum is
negligible and that's very true at less
than one atmosphere of pressure
however this becomes the driving force
behind oxygen hyperbaric oxygen therapy
because it's the dissolved oxygen that
actually leaves the red blood cell and
the microcirculation to penetrate tissue
and arrive at the site of action and so
the higher the dose of dissolved oxygen
we can achieve in serum the further we
can penetrate diseased and compromised
tissues this is seen in this example
again histogram here this is oxygen
saturation increasing oxygen saturation
and then just the frequency of the
samples these are experimental solid
tumors and what you can see is at normal
barrack air there's a large number of
hypoxic samples but as you increase the
oxygen to 100% oxygen or two atmospheres
and then finally to three or four
atmospheres the histogram is skewed way
over to the to the right to the highly
saturated region what's important about
this is you're reoxygenate imir but
you're also changing the the low end of
the the range and if if you look at the
percentage of the cancer that had less
than 5% saturation we see in air it's
about 16% and this represents the
refractory tumor cells that resist
therapy and if we can increase or
decrease this fraction we have can
expect enhanced tumor responses
anti-tumor responses so again this this
is just to point out that a hundred
percent oxygen may reoxygenate some
tissues but it doesn't achieve the end
in mind this is three liters of oxygen
and six liters of oxygen
were administered to try to drive up
Perry to Merle and intro to Merle
officers intentions and you can see we
see no significant change
however with hyperbaric oxygen we can
drive the partial pressure of oxygen up
into that tissue and then once they
leave the chamber there's a decay again
a decay that is approximately 20 minutes
or so this is probably the single most
important therapeutic slide that I have
and it's a it is distillation of years
of work from University of Pennsylvania
looking at the time intoxicated profile
of oxygen and this green bar represents
a hundred percent oxygen that is that is
available to hospitalized patients and
as you can see with a hundred percent
oxygen and with time this is the
pulmonary toxicity curve if it
approximates pulmonary oxygen toxicity
and we know that 100% oxygen beyond 24
hours we start to see pulmonary injury
this is long exposure low partial
pressure on hyperbaric oxygen works on
the other end of this equation of the
scale with a very short exposures but
high partial pressures and we're well
away from the pulmonary oxygen toxicity
however we do approximate the CNS oxygen
toxicity and there is a potential to
have a grand mal seizure
with this therapy however years of
testing this and using air brakes the
risk is less than 1 in 8,000 treatments
so now what what I would like to do is
quickly just say why additional evidence
for why we think hyperbaric oxygen is a
unique therapy and this is because it
has direct anti-inflammatory effects and
as I told you we're trying to reverse
hypoxia but we're also trying to to
decrease the inflammation within that
tumor and hyperbaric oxygen has been
shown to directly
inhibit inflammatory responses one
example of this is bovine endothelial
cells are human endothelial cells when
exposed in vitro to hypoxic conditions
will develop increased expression of it
adherence so-called I cam 1 in this
example but the important point is that
if the same cells are exposed to to the
hyperbaric oxygen it will reduce any
kind of increased expression in the
vascular endothelial cells so it can
reduce white cells sticking to
endothelium this is an animal model it
is a chemical colitis model which shows
that if you develop inflammation in
edema and colonic weight increases
however if you expose the animals to the
same toxins but treat with the
hyperbaric oxygen you can see a
significant reduction in the weight
suggesting that there's decreased
inflammation these authors further
looked at inflammatory cytokines which I
don't show you here and and they were
likewise reduced another example that
points out drug synergy is a carrageenan
model of inflammation in a rodent and
what you can see here is this is time
and this is swelling in the in the foot
pad and in saline treated animals their
significant swelling over time
anti-inflammatory medications reduce
this somewhat but are not complete
hyperbaric oxygen alone actually reduces
that inflammation and swelling greater
than the anti-inflammatory and when
combined with the anti-inflammatory
gets the best response
in humans this has also been shown an
age and a blister a human blister model
involves UV radiation and what we see
here again is this is the time this is
the size of the punch biopsy and what
you can see is there the appointment
size of the blister what you can see is
the inflammation is very high in the
first 24 to 48 hours however if the
patients receive hyperbaric oxygen it is
suppressed and then finally systemic
inflammation this associate with
inflammatory bowel disease was studied
in the late 90s and this just shows that
at the initiation of therapy very high
levels of il-1 treatment with hyperbaric
oxygen and reduce those systemic levels
and then it drops back up with cessation
of the hyperbaric treatment this is true
for il-6 and for TNF so this is
demonstration in a human that systemic
inflammation can be reduced by using
hyperbaric oxygen so the
anti-inflammatory effect is a intriguing
and important secondary effect of
hyperbaric oxygen and this is not seen
with a hundred percent oxygen so we
wondered if you were to add hyperbaric
oxygen to break both to attack both of
these limbs would you have improved and
improvement in
cancer responses others have gotten
interested because of the cumbersome
this and the difficulty of using
hyperbaric oxygen and the need for rigid
chambers developing drugs that will
mimic reoxygenate and all of these show
is as you would expect that if you can
increase the oxygen tension within the
tumor you can improve therapeutic
responses I find this seminars in cancer
biology and review of modulating the
micro tumor micro-environment
interesting there are many natural
products that are being tested
however they fail to address the natural
product of oxygen in this elegant review
and I suspect many of the compounds that
they propose to use again will be
impaired in terms of tissue penetration
within solid cancers so in summary I'd
like to say that the tumor
micro-environment is a major barrier to
the treatment of all solid cancers
oxygen is a drug that can be dosed and
delivered in a controlled and safe
manner and to Murray oxygenation therapy
may synergize with radiation chemo and
immune therapies this is the final
diagram to show you the model that we're
thinking of and we we think that that
the oxygen is going to synergize with
existing therapies so I could place
radiation and immunotherapy here as well
but that we suspect we can improve both
we're all conventional treatments so the
take-home message tumor micro
environment is hypoxic and inflamed and
resist treatment tumor we oxygenation
therapy can enhance current therapies
and hyperbaric oxygen will will be
needed and I think you know at this
advanced stage with metabolomics in and
gene therapy being used to think back on
doctor hunter's insight and that
inflammation itself is is not to be
considered a disease but is a salutary
operation but when it cannot accomplish
that salutary purpose it does mischief
and I think that's what we see within
the tumor microenvironment is the
hypoxia and inflammation are continuing
to cause mischief and poor outcomes I
thank you for your attention